neener neener neener neener neener neat
wave i to the camera good morning John
wanted to come your 11th in a most
entirely sure that I actually got the
day right this time
it's Wednesday it's all Wednesday this
song is Ottoman different than usual
because instead of recording with me in
my acoustic guitar and then later going
to the studio to record up for my album
I just recorded at the studio to start
with so you're getting the studio
version first-ever viewing here brother
du Bois know not only sure what to call
this song had a few ideas but I was
wondering if you guys had ideas as well
so if you could leave those in the
comment the best one I will choose and
then I'll link to your channel in the
sidebar which is actually over there
without further ado here's my song about
an anglerfish
yes it's true that I once went through
life is a guy who always had the rhyme
live where the strike is I've been
better I haven't burned through it all
yes I have burned I love this thought
about whether you get stubborn slower
than I did sir
because you can't eat the night if you
live your whole life without light you
can you've only ever eaten fishing again
feel alone if it's all you've ever
yeah the deep-sea application has a
reason to be happy about it have you
frigging idea what else giving the
teacher dwelling in Turkish there has to
find a feint they are all here together
when it's time to procreate see what our
nutty young applies a female on her side
and then slowly he becomes a sperm
producing Bears eye and if we could say
he little he was until she dies and
until that day he will really never
reach her song
like without lighting again you've only
ever eaten bitching again feel alone at
the toy you've ever
for years those rules got the other folk
whiskey spare you simply do not feel
what is always there a vibrate
entertainment pain is the same that if
might do it all the time can you really
call it in
I don't have any friends and I don't
have any hair but neither does the
imitation show doesn't care
because you can't eat the night with
your boy without like nicknames you've
only ever eaten
never duty ever - hunter isn't it
I hope that you enjoyed that please
don't forget to leave potential song
titles in the comments I need to get it
on with the song and secondarily dftba
records is having the dftba radio are
tonight in which todd lee 0 0 and
caitlin sky will be talking about all
things nearly all things dftba all
things musical all things awesome 9 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time
there's a link in the sidebar John I
hope you enjoyed my music I enjoyed your
question Tuesday and I especially
enjoyed captain Willie's voyage on the
fail boat don't forget to be awesome